le matin quand je me mets célébrer le
premier réflexe est allé porter plainte
monsieur voilà et puis après j'avais
peur aujourd'hui un peu ouais j'avoue
que j'ai peur pour ma si oui alors on
est avec vous dire vous êtes le patron
du restaurant le bras ce coût à cergy
qu'est ce qui s'est passé hier soir ben
moi j'ai pris j'étais content ce qui
s'est passé ce matin au réveil quoi
d'accord vous étiez pas la guerre soit
pas du tout d'accord faut savoir que le
restaurant à partir de 21h il ya une
seule personne qui est en cuisine vu
qu'on est en fermeture il ya une seule
personne qui est en cuisine cette
personne qu'on voit sur les images
elle travaille pas dans mon restaurant
l'a jamais travaillé dans rouge c'est
l'agresseur pour vous ne venez pas il
n'est pas dans votre restaurant
aucunement dans mon restaurant
il a déjà été formellement identifiés
ils ne travaillent pas dans mon
restaurant
donc c'est pas quelqu'un qui bosse dans
mon restaurant en fait j'avais 80
connaissiez se garent pas du tout il y
avait quatre individus qui sont baladés
sur le parvis
à partir de 22h30 et qu'ils voulaient
manger sauf que on ne sert plus en
présentiel ont fait que des livraisons
via les plateformes c'est pour ça qu'un
livreur qui vient prendre une commande
et à partir de ce moment là il ya eu un
écheveau fort et il semblerait que la
personne qui vous a insulté s'en est
pris aux livreurs pour lui dire ouais
des pour l'insulter et à partir de ce
moment là ils l'ont agressé mais votre
livreur vous le connaissiez ah non moi
j'ai pas vivre un mois adacore ah non
moi je pense que le port des plates
formes comme une accord bury voilà je
n'ai pas d'aigreur d'accord donc c'est
un livreur qui est venu récupérer une
sauce à d'accord un client et à ce
moment là où il récupère la commande il
ya quatre individus qui qui se mettent
sur lui et qui lui demande qui veulent
intervenir pour rentrer dans le
restaurant que c'est un acte raciste
internet puisque le racisme c'est un non
mais c'est plus que raciste là c'est
inimaginable ces odieuses qui s'est
passé non mais moi si ce que vous dites
aux gens qui disent que cela sonne ils
avaient ils ont ils ont parce que je
sais que guy roux jean ton nom mais
j'entends vos témoignages et je le
respecte la juste avant l'émission il y
avait des dizaines de jeunes de cergy
qui était devant les studios qui m'ont
tous affirmé que sept personnes
travailler chez vous on a aussi
recueilli le témoignage d'un client
régulier de 5 qui ont réglé de votre
restaurant on peut peut-être l'écouté
reconnaître ce jeune homme qui
s'appellerait mois
donc et qui avait déjà un comportement
problématique avec les clients des
malheurs des mois je vous affirme que ge
a aucun mort a qui a travaillé dans mon
restaurant
aucunement toutes les vidéos de manière
peu pendant quinze jours de mon
restaurant moi de donner à la police
pour qu'ils puissent vérifier toutes les
scènes qui bosse dans mon raisonnement
tout sera fait pour blanchir moi ni mon
restaurant je vous assure qu'il n'a
jamais travaillé chez moi toute cette
histoire
malheureusement c'est triste pour madame
c'est triste pour le livreur mais c'est
triste pour moi aussi je n'y suis
absolument pour rien toutes les
personnes toutes les personnes qui
parlent de cette vidéo là je suis je
suis ça n'est pas mon livreur ça n'est
pas une personne qui bosse chez moi et
me bonnes personnes qui sont venus ce
matin dans mon restaurant
il ya une dame qui est venu à 10 heures
du matin pour s'exprimer et et me dire
mais je comprends pas je connais tous
vos tous vos salariés ça n'est pas
possible
quand je vois ça c'est honteux je lui
explique elle me dit oui je connais vos
les personnes ki mo chez vous il ne
bosse pas chez vous et je n'ai pas une
personne qui bossent en bandoulière avec
un en survêtement dans mon restaurant
ça n'est pas possible et sincèrement je
vous assure que moi je suis poli à 3000
team dans cette dans cette histoire il
ya madame il ya le livreur et ya moi je
n'ai aucunement aucunement il a
travaillé chez beaucoup plus de victimes
quand on voit les images parce qu'il
assure qu' on est tous bien sûr bien sûr
je vous dire tous les gens qui nous dira
ce soir et on peut passer images sont
insoutenables et est-ce que ça choix on
va en parler avec mes 11 een dans un
instant cc c'est incroyable ce qui s'est
passé et on a on a un témoignage guillou
il avait recueilli alors vous allez nous
dire ce que je zoome byrnes on a envie
de vous croire aussi
voilà c'est super il ya il ya un mineur
un client régulier du restaurant venu
ici exprès pour un surnom mais c'est
bien on vous dirait bien sinon je serais
pas venu ici et qui dit que ça ne fait
pas un livre mais quelqu'un qui serait à
la caisse et qui aurait déjà eu des
comportements problématiques on l'a tous
il ya pas de souci
de plus pas très longtemps
non seulement 5 et d'autre la question
est oui en plus des gestions étude
rappelle aujourd'hui en porte le montant
qu est ce que est ce que c'est possible
nous dire que vous êtes fait trahir par
un nouveau salarié par exemple vous
n'êtes pas sur place dans votre
restaurant et qui a un pote qui appelle
un pote pour dire mais tu encaisses pour
donner un coup de main et que vous
veniez tpo courra du tout c'est
impossible simple aussi impossible que
nous avec se remettent et sa bandoulière
et rentrent chez eux nous assure que
barbara aussi je vous le jure et je vous
l'assuré que ça je ne crois pas du tout
petit j'ai deux personnes qui
travaillent à ma caisse
il ya deux personnes ils font rentrer
personne d'autre dans un restaurant 5 0l
un restaurant un jour tu mens il ya la
has à partir de 21h il ya une seule
personne qui prend la tablette et qui
est en cuisine c'est pour ça qu'elle n'a
pas pu assister la personne qui a eu des
problèmes dehors parce qu'elle ne voit
pas ce qui se passe elle est en cuisine
elle a juste une tablette elle prend la
commande est la donne au livreur j'ai
déjà donné d'autres vidéos où vous avez
pu voir que les livrets ribéry de
rentrer dans mon restaurant et qui a à
ce moment là il ya une personne qui vit
donne la commande est aucunement
aucunement cette personne travaille dans
mon restaurant et je voulais et je vous
la firme est vraiment vraiment je peux
je peux alors j'espère que la justice
sera faite et vous verrez aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il ya des dizaines de
personnes qui sont rassemblés dans votre
restaurant pas des dizaines ya eu des
centaines et centaines à cergy tous ont
dû chercher l'auteur des propos proférés
hier soir regardez
sordo des différents patois me maguet
pourquoi attendre que l'histoire de la
dignité c'est pas une histoire de ce
stage sert à rien c'est vrai que quand
on voit ce qui s'est passé quand on voit
ces images on a envie de faire un appel
au calme et on est on se dit c'est pas
possible d'en arriver là c'est moi vous
voulez vous dis je les comprends je suis
obligé de les comprendre les gens bien
sûr ça c'est horrible ce qui a été dit
forcément on dit on dit qu'il travaille
chez moi forcément je comprends qu'il
vienne et vienne je veux moi je veux que
la lumière soit faite sur cette histoire
le plus rapidement possible
vraiment vraiment je veux que ce soit
fait je veux vraiment que la personne
soit interpellé jours vous avez été
victime quoi d'inde à non mais moi je
suis victime d'un mec qui n'a qui n'a
jamais travaillé chez moi je vous le
jure je vous le promets c'est le pire
truc qui puisse m'arriver dans ma vie
j'ai tout fait franchement mon
restaurant il est très bien il est bien
notée en ad on a des bonnes critiques
les gens les gens qui viennent manger
chez moi je n'ai jamais dérapages cette
personne n'a jamais travaillé chez moi
comment